voyons plus en détail comment le canada
se compare à d'autres pays développés
pour soir frédéric cette tendance à elle
existe donc un peu partout oui c'est
généralisé en fait sur les trente
dernières années dans tous les pays
développés
l'écart de revenus et de richesse entre
les plus pauvres et les plus riches
c'est évidemment creuser aujourd'hui en
fait 10% des plus riches gagnent dix
fois plus que 10% des plus pauvres donc
c'est une constante là ça monte ça monte
maintenant comment ce qu'on parle
justement le canada par rapport au reste
du monde dont l ocde justement a fait la
compilation avec les 34 pays membres et
on est vraiment juste en dessous de la
moyenne donc quand on se compare on va
dire qu'on se console dans ce cas ci
parce que lorsqu'on regarde justement
les pays où c'est cet écart est vraiment
vraiment le pire c'est au chili gagnant
toutes catégories ensuite le mexique la
turquie et les états unis qui fait
partie donc de ce classement peu
enviable des pays où cet écart est le
plus grand maintenant quand on se
compare aussi on se désole parce qu'il
ya des situations qui sont bien
meilleurs dans d'autres pays par exemple
c'est au danemark en fait que l'écart de
richesse est le plus faible et la
slovénie la slovaquie la norvège
d'islande
donc on voit évidemment ce sont les pays
scandinaves qui sont les pays riches qui
ont fait des choix de société où il ya
vraiment là filet social qui est
beaucoup plus fort que dans d'autres
pays
et quand même un mot sur le canada vous
savez eu la crise économique en 2008 le
canada a plutôt bien résisté et c'est au
québec en fait que cet écart des
inégalités est le plus faible du filet
social
évidemment c'est un choix société alors
comment réduire cet écart met rapidement
en fait le cda a donné donc 3,4 points à
suivre d'abord il faudrait promouvoir
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes en
termes de revenus parce que c'est un
gros facteur d'inégalité également
investir dans l'éducation élargir les
compétences et finalement ce serait
mieux répartir la richesse en taxant
davantage les plus riches et les
entreprises
est-ce que ça a été fait me poser la
question c'est y répondre